it is the christmas season it is could i
ask you for one last song
the famous uh please come home for
christmas song this is a great uh
classic right i would love to many
people have recorded this
many people it was written by a
gentleman from new orleans named charles
brown who is deceased now yes but you
guys uh you do a beautiful job with it
right uh well i hope so yeah here it is
for the holiday season
[Music]
bells will be ringing
the sad sad news
oh what a christmas
[Music]
my baby's gone
i have no friends
you wish me greetings
[Music]
christmas carols
[Music]
back into life
[Music]
please come home for christmas
please come home for christmas
if not for christmas
[Music]
by new year's night
friends and relations
since salutations
[Music]
so this is christmas
yeah christmas
is the time of year
to be
with the one you love
so won't you tell me
[Music]
there'll be no more sorrow
[Music]
no grief and pain
and i'll be happy
happy
watch
[Music]
little
again
[Music]
christmas
once again
[Music]
it's beautiful